is
i'm sorry
did you see mark meadows the chief of
staffer did any pass
no i don't see it
who's that camera somebody on
two middle mornings
um
[Music]
uh
thank you
yep
all right take care
good afternoon everyone the radicals are
in control
of the democrat party make no mistake
democrat radicals want to shatter
norms and disregard precedent for the
sake of the very
norms and precedent they claim must be
safeguarded
they've proposed court packing an
egregious idea
they've entertained impeachment as
punishment for the president exercising
his
lawful article 2 section 2 authority
to appoint uh nominate rather a justice
to the supreme court
they've advocated for the abolition of
the electoral college
these are all the tactics that they are
using to sow chaos
and discord likewise they're endorsing a
mass
mail out ballot system that will likely
lead to the kind of
week-long delay new york witnessed in
its recent primary
far-left radicals resort to tactics like
this to push their extreme agenda
because they cannot win
on the merits they cannot succeed based
on the will of the american people
this administration will continue to
call out these tactics while democrats
should end
their petty politics and get to work and
with that i'll take questions
john yeah kelly i wanted to just clean
up or clarify
something the president said yesterday
if he loses this election can you assure
us
that there will be a peaceful transfer
of power
you are referring to the question asked
by the playboy reporter right
i'm referring to with the president
being asked if there would be a peaceful
principle of power
i believe that question asked by the
playboy power in fact i think i have it
right here uh he was asked he was asked
when lose or draw whether he would
accept the transfer of power i'm not
entirely sure if he won why he would
accept
a transfer of power that is um maybe the
deranged wish of that reporter but
that's not how
governing very direct a very simple
question if the president loses this
election
will this white house will this
president assure us that there will be a
peaceful transfer of power
it's a very simple point the president
the president will
accept the results of a free and fair
election
but i think that your question is more
fitting to be asked of democrats who
have already been on the record saying
they won't accept the results of an
election
um in fact i have several of them here
for you south carolina democrat
jim clyburn has said that trump is not
going to win fairly
senator barbara boxer has said that the
only way trump will win
is to steal it that's according to
democrat senator barbara boxer
the washington post has noted they have
a headline democrats may not trust the
results of the election if trump
wins and then you have uh that beautiful
quote from hillary quint clinton that
joe biden should not concede under any
circumstance so
i think your fitting is more question
more uh fitting question for democrats
yeah okay uh kayleigh just understand
this clearly are the results
legitimate only if the president wins
the president will accept the results of
a
free and fair election he will accept
the will of the american people for
clarity if he loses and it's free and
fair he will accept it i've answered
your question he will accept the results
of a free and fair election
let me ask you about briana taylor if i
can right now first of all just a little
housekeeping
has the president spoken to the family
of rihanna taylor
i'm not aware of any conversation that
they've had but our hearts do go out to
our family has the president spoken to
the officers who were shot last night in
louisville
i'm not aware of any conversations so
the president spoke to the officers who
were shot in los angeles but to this
point
there's no indication the president at
any point of the last several months
has spoken to the family of brianna
taylor i guess the president routinely
um speaks to victims of horrendous
um tragedies i've been here when he's
met with the parents who lost
their children to instances of police
brutality and it was a really beautiful
meeting and the president consoled them
he's talked to the
widows who have lost their husbands
police officers
he's spoken to widows of fallen soldiers
he routinely reaches out to victims of
all kinds of atrocities and he'll
continue to do that what is the
president's message to the family of
brianna i heard what you say
we grieve for them what is the
president's message to the family of
brianna taylor that does not believe
they received justice that our hearts go
out to her it was a horrible
tragedy that happened and that our
hearts also are with the two police
officers who were shot last night and
the louisville rights when you say
you mean you mean the white house
including the president i speak on
behalf of the president
his thoughts go out i am the president
spokesperson i speak
yesterday when the president said get
rid of the ballots there won't be a
transfer frankly there'll be a
continuation
which particular ballots is he talking
about wanting to get rid of and what
does he think that would help him get
elected
uh the president wants to get rid of
mass mail out
voting um and that's not because it he
said clearly that that could go either
way it could damage either candidates
chances because it's a system that's
subject to fraud in fact in the last
24 hours police in greenville wisconsin
found
mail in a ditch and it included absentee
ballots
um and also i can confirm for you that
trump
ballots ballots for the president were
found in pennsylvania and i believe you
should be getting more information on
that shortly here in the last
24 hours they were found cast aside so
why in the past hour did the president
tweet out
vote by mail ballots in my home state of
florida begin going out today make sure
to request yours fill it out and send it
in the president has always made the
distinction that absentee ballots where
you go through a process where you
request
a ballot i mean you mail that in that is
a system that works but a system where
you mass mail out to voter rolls which
are not kept and maintained where in
los angeles county for instance you have
120 percent of the county enrolled
that system is untenable it doesn't work
it leads to what we saw in nevada where
there were ballots languishing
and trash cans and pin to apartment
boards
today fbi director ray testified on the
hill that he has not seen historically
any kind of coordinated national voter
fraud effort
in a major election whether it's by male
or otherwise
so if the president's own fbi director
says this isn't a problem
why does the president keep saying it is
well as attorney general barr has said
we've never had an election where we've
done mass mail out voting like this
before
i would point you to a bipartisan study
um done by none other than jimmy carter
who said that
these mail and votes remained the
largest source of potential fraud and he
even cited an example
of a 1997 miami mayor election that
resulted in 36 arrests for absentee
ballot fraud that election had to be
rerun and the results
were reversed uh that is an example from
1997 but there are many others like
patterson new jersey where four men were
charged with voting fraud recently
four more men were charged in california
and there's a ton of examples i could
get you an encyclopedia
of fraudulent examples we've had ballots
are going out if the president
does win will he still think it was
rigged and projected
i've already answered this question yes
kaylee
the president's niece filed a lawsuit in
new york state court today
alleging that the president and two of
his siblings
had cheated her out of millions and
squeezed her out of the family business
and we were hoping to get reaction from
the white house
yeah the only fraud committed there was
mary trump recording
one of her relatives and uh she's really
discredited herself
yes kaylee on tick tock we know that the
scythias negotiations are continuing can
you say has the president been
briefed in the last couple days about
how the syphia's negotiations are going
do you know when those negotiations will
end
yeah not that i'm not aware of the brief
his briefing schedule with regard to
tick tock but what i can say
is what the president has said which is
that any deal has to be 100 percent as
far as national
security is concerned and i'd refer you
uh to his comments as well as
of those uh from the department of
treasury for any further specifics i'd
refer you there
yes jeff vicki the president suggested
yesterday that he might overrule
stricter standards at the fda on the
corona coronavirus vaccine
why would the president not want strict
standards for a vaccine on the
coronavirus
well the fda does have strict standards
they are
the gold standard with regard to
vaccines the president was referring to
the normal interagency
process that happens with guidance and
that includes
running through on the office of
management and budget so that's standard
operating procedure
and i would also point out i spoke to dr
han this morning
um and dr han said that the guidance
issued was a follow-up to june
30th guidance that they put out and it
was um guidance it was
guidance that they gave to
pharmaceutical companies to provide them
with more regulatory
clarity the white house is describing
this healthcare event today as a chance
for the president to
outline his vision is that something
less than his plan
and just a second part of that does the
white house think that it can address
the country's challenges with health
care solely through executive action
so um the president will be laying out
on his health care vision today i don't
want to get ahead of exactly what that
will look like there will be
some tangible actions taken as well as
the president really laying out which i
something that i think has been
overlooked the real contrast between
what obamacare gave us between 2013 and
2017
and what the president has delivered um
and
and i think we have a graphic to that
effect i'm not sure if they were able to
put it together in time but with
obamacare it is a fact that from 2013 to
2017
premiums in this country went up in fact
they went up by 105
on the individual market um and you
contrast that with president trump what
he's managed to do
by rolling back a lot of obamacare and
we've seen premiums on the individual
market go down
same for medicare part d and medicare
advantage the polar opposite of what
happened with obamacare where those
premiums went
up so premiums have come down under this
president
drug prices have come down under
president obama drug prices were up 15
um under president trump they came down
for the first time in
50 years um and then finally under
obamacare
you had choice that went down one-third
of counties had only one insurer in the
individual market
i mean with president trump there are
new affordable options like ahps
stldis and hras healthcare reimbursement
arrangements
as well as employer-sponsored insurance
um that has gone up we've seen
an increase of 1.5 million in 2019. so
these principles
have undergirded the trump presidency
and he will use many of the same
principles going forward and you'll get
his comprehensive health care vision
that will include some action
items um here in short order of the plan
or is there more
after this this is going to be his full
vision that he has been talking about
over the last few weeks
and it'll be in charlotte north carolina
today yes
thanks so much kaylee i wanted to ask
about the supreme court
considerations um has the president met
with all the top candidates that are
under consideration
are there any others who else is he are
there any others that he still plans to
meet
judge lagoa for example does he still
plan to meet with judge lugo
so i'm not going to get into the
president's private meetings with these
candidates he's noted that there are
five he's considering they all fall in
the same mold as
textualists originalists constitution
abiding judges
today at the supreme court uh when the
president
approached uh you know was was paying
his respect
to justice ginsburg there were some
people in the crowd
that started the chance uh to uh
respect her wishes to uphold her wishes
um
do you have some thoughts on those
chants which also you know included vote
him out
yeah i think the the chants were
appalling but certainly to be expected
when you're in the heart of the swamp i
travel with the president
all across the country pennsylvania
north carolina florida nevada and
everywhere we go
the streets are lined with support like
i don't think any other president has
had previously
but with regard to precedent as i've
noted before
29 times has an appointment uh been made
in an election year um 29 times that was
all 29 times um when there was a vacancy
at hand so the president is very much on
our side here
and i would also note the hypocrisy of
democrats joe biden saying
i would go forward with the confirmation
process as chairman even a few months
before an election
uh barack obama saying fill the supreme
court vacancy when
it was his tenure and you had kamala
harris saying as well
uh that senate gop is holding scotus
hostage for political gain join me in
calling them to consider
president obama's nominee so they've
really flipped here because the
president
is on our side and their hypocrisy is on
full display yes
the former number two of the joint
chiefs of staff
paul selva who served under president
trump he and
500 other national security and military
leaders they endorsed joe biden today
if you guys have a comment on that given
that it doesn't seem like jim mattis and
joe dunford who also served
under the president are rushing to
support him this election
yeah i think the president's record
speaks for itself our military men and
women our veterans
love this president for a very distinct
reason under obama biden
sequestration really gutted our military
you had the navy at its smallest point
ever and the other military branches
were absolutely gutted then you had
president trump who came in
and secured a record amount of funding
for our military and our department
of defense and built up our military um
when it comes to veterans the appalling
way that our veterans were treated at
the va under obama biden there was an ig
report that as many as 300
000 veterans think about that 300 000
veterans
could have died waiting for care this
president came in put in the va missions
act secured real choice and options for
our veterans
um and that's the reason that the
military and our veterans love this
president
i can't speak to one person's reasoning
but uh this president when you look at
what he's done
on bringing our troops home and all he's
done in aggregate the rank and file in
this military
love this president yes thanks kaylee
two quick follow-ups on what's in this
customer earlier does the president
still have confidence in the fda
commissioner based on his kindness
yesterday
um there are no changes dr hahn is fda
commissioner so yes
and so you said that you thought the
chance outside the supreme court this
morning were appalling
uh is there any issue with people
peacefully demonstrating and chanting at
the president no of course everyone has
a first amendment in this country but i
thought it was
an appalling and disrespectful thing to
do as the president on it honored
justice ginsburg
yes what was the emergency call the
president left yesterday's briefing to
take
um i'm not going to get into a readout
of the president's calls but he
regularly takes very important phone
calls
yes thank you definitely um what's the
likelihood that sudan will be the next
country to recognize
israel are there any new developments
you're expecting
after the emirates and bahrain
recognized israel so the president has
noted that there are several other
countries that want to make agreements
of this sort and i
won't confirm exactly which country will
be next but rest assured the world has
looked at what this president did
historic agreements between the uae uh
and
israel and bahrain and do you see deals
that like you haven't seen in a quarter
of a century it was 26 years
um between the second uh and the third
deal and just 29 days between the third
and the fourth this president's the only
president
to have um overseeing the normalization
of relations um between
israel and two middle east countries um
to have two on his watch is a really big
deal
and no wonder uh two nobel peace prize
nominations as well
yes will we yeah thank you uh what's the
status of
corner virus vaccination this year do
you expect this to be available before
christmas
um we do expect to have a vaccine by the
end of the year uh that has always been
the goal and we are still on track for
that
it's very important that what the
president has done
with regard to commercial level
manufacturing as uh dr salawi told me
the fact that you
have scaled up to manufacture these
vaccines in advance
is a something that this president has
done he's a businessman and thinks
through
exactly how to get a safe and effective
vaccine delivered at record speed and
part of that has entailed
manufacturing in advance and to do this
it normally takes years to scale up to
commercial level production but this
president has done it
in just a few short months and if we
have this vaccine by the end of the year
it will be the fastest pace for a
vaccine for a novel pathogen
in history yes thank you kaylee i wanted
to go back to mail in voting for just a
bit right now
five states conduct elections entirely
by mail-in
prior to the pandemic with no cases or
no major cases
of fraud does that success not give the
president's
confidence in mail-in voting so those
states have um
had time and a history of doing a
having a workable system and one that
has been done for
many years for many election cycles to
move the entire country to mass mail and
voting all at once and have an entirely
uh new system and do that in just a few
short months is
an untenable and an unworkable
proposition i mean one that has shown
uh to not work well at all especially
when you look at the disenfranchisement
which i think is
is really uh troubling when it comes to
mass mail and voting
um in 2016 you had one percent of
ballots thrown out
absentee ballots that amounted to 319
000 votes
thrown out and if you have the entirety
of the country voting by mail
you can imagine that number would be
many folds higher than that and you look
just in the primary where you've seen
states try to move to this mass mail-in
system
uh there were 100 000 ballots rejected
in california in new york
city one in five mail-in ballots were
rejected
and as a former doj voting rights
official said
um it's nuts that is just way too high
when one in five voters because of mass
mail and voting
have their ballots thrown out yes
thank you kaley uh yesterday the senate
released an 87 page report on hunter
biden and joe biden's dealings
across the board of ukraine and with
russia
specifically it showed hunter biden
supporting russian prostitution human
trafficking
receiving 3.5 million dollars from
moscow
question here is does the white house
have any intention of helping the doj
should an investigation be opened up on
the guidance and number two
do you have a response to rudy giuliani
yesterday telling us that
um this should immediately disqualify
joe biden from
his candidacy yeah that was a very
troubling report you know i'll leave it
to the doj as to how they move forward
but i mean i think this new york post
cover uh says it all you know i heard so
much about russia collusion
but it appears the only collusion going
on was between hunter biden as he
accepted 3.5
million dollars from the wife
of the moscow mayor very troubling
indeed in addition to that ukraine money
as well
and it's good that the senate looked
into that but finally
i would like to note the situation in
louisville kentucky
last night there were reports of
vandalism there were nearly a hundred
arrests and the trump administration
urges calm and reminds
those who wish to have their voices
heard to do so peacefully
you have a right to peaceful protest as
outlined in the first amendment
and the attorney general daniel cameron
said if we simply act on emotion or
outrage there is no justice mob justice
is
not justice justice sought by violence
is not
justice it just becomes revenge and you
contrast his message
with that of cnn's brianna keeler who
said i question the judgment of the
kentucky attorney general saying that
mob justice
is not justice we know that this is very
loaded language
that's an appalling statement from
briana keeler at cnn and what is
outrageous
about this take is that mob justice is
not
justice hours later after this comment
was made
on cnn two police officers were shot
this is not justice this has nothing to
do with politics it has everything to do
with the value of human life and the
safety
and security of our american cities and
across the country
we've seen our police officers come
under fire in the line of duty in los
angeles there was an ambush attempt
on two police officers in phoenix a u.s
marshal was ambushed and shot outside a
federal courthouse in linwood california
a suspect approached a patrol car and
fired a handgun into the passenger side
window
and in suffolk virginia a suspect opened
fired
on a marked police car hitting the
vehicle three times
our police officers deserve our respect
and the violence that is being committed
towards them and this was just in the
last
week and a half uh is outrageous and the
words of of cnn and of briana keeler are
outrageous
irresponsible and we should never hear
statements like that followed by
hours later two police officers being
shot
haley what does the president believe
you